So this last bit of code with the legend, we've put our circles in.
Now we want to append text.
For the text SVG instead of cy it's simple y, there's no center to the text.
Instead of cx, it's simply x,
since we only need to specify the y and the x of where we want to draw the text.
In here, while it may seem somewhat arbitrary we've actually drawn the text
at the same position i times 30 as each of the circles, but
this is actually going to draw the text.
Slightly higher, since it's going to draw the bottom of the text
at position i 30, and we actually want the center of
our text to be in line with the center of our circle.
So in our case, the default text is 10 pixels tall, so half of 10 is five,
and this will position it perfectly.
In line with the circle, and for the radius what might seem arbitrary of five,
we simply drawn it five radii over from the circle itself, and
again, for these values, they might seem hardcoded here.
We can simply experiment and change them up or
down to achieve a different effect and once we visually are happy we
can set them in our code or abstract them into variables higher up.
The last bit here simply changes the text attribute of the text SVG element.
And since we've bound strings as data.
D, in this case, is simply a string, either home team or others, and
we can just return the datum itself without any further transformation.
Saving our file, let's go back to the browser.
And voila, we now have proper labels, home team and others, so that our
readers know which the red circles represent, what the blue circles represent.
It can draw their own conclusions given the information we've presented them.
Well we may have seen red circles early on being much higher attended.
Every reader might interpret this chart and find something different and
new depending on where they're coming from.
What their pre-existing biases are, and
what relation they might have to the data.